[Music]
[Applause]
alright here's how the survey works we
ask three celebrities to complete a
phrase our first phrase was the most
recent episode of Game of Thrones was
Seth Rogen said shocking Amy Poehler
said horrifying Bill Clinton said
depressingly free of nudity there's one
when I heard Kanye and Kim were having a
girl I thought nicole kidman said I hope
that they raised her to be a strong
independent woman Ty Burrell said I hope
they let her grow up out of the public
eye Kris Jenner wrote how much will
playboy pay me for her sonogram
our favorite father-son activity is
Damon Wayans and Damon Wayans Jr wrote
playing ping-pong Prince Charles and
Prince Harry roat going horseback riding
Will Smith and Jaden Smith wrote wasting
America's time and money the hardest
thing about owning pets is Jake
Gyllenhaal wrote having to leave them
when I travel kaley cuoco wrote taking
care of them when they're sick Stephen
Tyler wrote having cats mistake my face
for a scratching standing still for so
long when I heard that Michael Douglas
got throat cancer from giving oral sex
to too many women I thought Julie Bowen
wrote why can't that I'm sorry that
can't be the reason okay that was my
mistake
man let me try this one run the
beginning when I heard Michael Douglas
got throat cancer I'm giving oral sex
into many women I thought Julie Bowen
wrote that can't be the reason Harlan
Williams wrote is that medically sound
Ryan Seacrest wrote I'm going to live
forever
I feel most creative when I'm Steve
Martin wrote painting in my studio Zach
Braff wrote directing independent films
Steven Seagal wrote touring craft fairs
with my homemade yarn he has really
calmed down
I hate being recognized in Jeff Goldblum
wrote restaurants Paul Rudd wrote public
bathrooms Nicolas Cage wrote any recent
film I've made I'm making a lot of
friends here someday I'd like to
experience Megan Mullally wrote
skydiving Sarah Chalke wrote an African
safari guy fieri wrote shame I take care
of my skin with Kate Beckinsale wrote
moisturizer
Jane Lynch wrote cold cream Bruce Jenner
wrote cowboy Roy saddle butter
[Applause]
sure I can't stop smiling my friends
think it's weird that I Harrison Ford
wrote still have an earring
Norm Macdonald wrote don't drive a
fancier car Michael Douglas wrote used
40 postage stamps for every piece of
mail that I send what can I say that's
my that's my Michael Douglas impression
and finally to teach me about art my
parents would drag me to Elijah Wood
wrote the Guggenheim John Krasinski
wrote the Art Institute of Chicago Larry
King wrote a cave
[Applause]